[Música]
decimos a favor del aborto,
lloré y le grité un poco a mi
compañero de cuarto y estábamos muy
decepcionados y
desanimados con
el estado de la sociedad de que esto podría
estar sucediendo
[Música]
no vamos  para ir en silencio vamos
a recaudar fondos para los frentes de aborto
vamos a ayudar a las personas en los estados rojos a
abortar en los estados azules donde
capacitará a las personas sobre cómo hacer un
aborto autogestionado que es muy, muy
seguro y vamos  para contraatacar
[Música]
oh
es el principio hasta el final
porque nosotros, eh, la corte suprema es
recta por la opinión pública, por lo que
tenemos que movilizar masivamente el
poder de la gente para decir que la reversión del
peso es buena, lo hará.  salvar vidas y
eso es bueno y deben seguir
adelante
[Música]